[Music]
meet murphy
hi
he's a happy dog in his golden years but
to his owner chris dapowski murphy is
living proof that 3d printers will
change the world
i just call my bionic dog
because that's what he is half of his
skull is bionic science fiction is now
become science reality
not long ago murphy's reality was grim
it was like this hard
ball on the top of his hedge it's almost
like it appeared out of nowhere and then
it turned out to be this very rare form
of cancer basically what they have to do
is take part of the skull out i kind of
went into this panic state like
okay where do we go from here
chris's search led her to the university
of guelph
here veterinary surgeon dr michelle
oblak is pioneering the use of 3d
printers to help prepare for the most
complicated operations
so this is murphy this is his exact
skull we've actually taken the cat scan
specifically from him and we've printed
this model so this is the tumor in red
and so as you'll notice
when we remove the tumor and that
portion of bone to get to the deeper
surface
there's quite a bit of murphy's brain as
well as the front of his sinus exposed
so it's a pretty big area that we need
to cover
to rebuild murphy's skull
dr o black also used murphy's cat scans
as a template to create this
a 3d printed plate custom built out of
solid titanium
in murphy's case because we had this 3d
plate
we could go ahead and just create the
plate to fit perfectly
it fits very easily
and like a glove right onto that surface
[Music]
to truly appreciate murphy's miracle go
back about a decade to when 3d printing
was widely seen as a gimmick
today's 3d printers are bigger faster
and smarter than ever
the phrase 3d printing is an umbrella
term for the multitude of technologies
that use computer models to create solid
objects one layer at a time
material extrusion is what most people
picture 3d printing to be
a liquefied material is squeezed out
through a nozzle and then hardens and a
solid 3d shape is born
this is the least expensive and least
refined way to 3d print
with that polymerization a beam of uv
light is scanned across a vat of liquid
resin curing it instantly
this technique creates smooth surfaces
with delicate details but is mostly
limited to plastics
then there's powder bed fusion
here the material is a fine powder and
when it's hit with an energy source the
individual grains fuse together
this creates high quality and complex
objects out of plastic ceramic or even
metal
that's what they do here at anubis 3d in
mississauga ontario
it really feels like when you're a kid
and you're baking cookies and you just
want to watch it through the oven door
and wait for it to be ready the only
thing that you cannot open it now
because we lose the batch
let's not spoil the batch
tharwat fuad started this company in
2012. since then his industry has
completely transformed
we spent years trying to
push the technologies and it wasn't
happening right now it started to become
accepted as a mainstream manufacturing
process 3d printing aka additive
manufacturing offers some enticing
advantages over traditional techniques
like less waste reduced operating and
production costs
and increased speed
the time it takes to design
for additive
it's longer but the manufacturing type
is a lot less the manufacturing process
in additive manufacturing
is
days same day two days if you go out
with the same equivalent part to a cnc
shop and say i need this part it's
couple of weeks so the fact that it's
much faster must be great news for your
customers what are you hearing from them
this was a very nice surprise
for the very early stages
the first time second time but then
after that they start ordering very late
so
they are disappointed that you cannot
deliver it the same day they've been a
little spoiled yeah
that's the point yeah
the ability of on-demand manufacturing
to reduce overseas production and
shipping costs could be a game changer
during a supply chain crunch
and there's another advantage to this
technology
you can also do things
that are
small but very intricate the red piece
comes out with all the gears and the
shafts inside it and they're able to
rotate right out of the machine as the
moving parts in a sub-assembly printed
as one piece those are things you cannot
do with machining it's impossible to do
with machining
[Music]
3d printing is creating a world of
possibilities and not just in the
manufacturing sector
hey cam we're two layers away
deep in the bc interior jim zimlanski
and his team at twente additive
manufacturing are using a specially
built 3d printer to flip the world of
construction on its head
3d concrete printing will play a very
important role in the future of
affordable housing the construction
industry is one of the largest
industries in the world
and it's ripe for automation
automation once again cuts down on labor
dramatically making it easier faster and
therefore cheaper to build a home
you know it's like a photocopier you can
hit copy copy
as much as you like
to prove their technology works jim's
team designed and built the first ever
fully 3d printed home on canadian soil
welcome to the fibonacci house
[Music]
from floor to ceiling this place has 3d
printed concrete everywhere you look
we've even gone ahead and printed some
of the fixtures in the building here
so here's a sink that we printed
and the fibonacci house caught the eye
of a bc community that's in need of some
new homes fast
the people of merit suffered enormously
in 2021 a summer of devastating
wildfires followed by record-breaking
floods a lot of residents were displaced
from their homes and they're still
displaced the city of merit has
approached us and asked us if we would
be able to assist with our technology
we'll be printing 20 homes in merit and
they'll be 550 square feet each we've
calculated the build time for each home
should be about 12 hours
if the merit project is a success it
could cement 3d printing as a solution
to the housing crisis across canada and
around the world
it's like a new frontier where people
can still imagine
new things that people haven't imagined
before
meanwhile in north carolina they're
banking on the next big thing in biotech
3d printing at the cellular level if you
take one human hair and split it down
longitudinally 50 times
that's how small we can get in terms of
the resolution dr anthony atala runs the
wake forest institute for regenerative
medicine their proprietary 3d printers
use human cells as the raw material to
print living tissues and maybe one day
whole organs
sounds like sci-fi but it's real the
current organ shortage is very serious
in fact over a 10-year period the number
of patients on the transplant list has
gone up tenfold
bio-engineered organs could solve that
problem but historically building a
blood supply to the tissues deep inside
complex organs like the heart liver and
lungs was impossible
now 3d printing may hold the key
we print these cells layer by layer one
at a time and by doing so we also create
this highway system if you will
that brings nutrition to the central
portion of that printed construct
allowing it to survive
as dr atala and his team push the
frontiers of biotech
what are you doing what are you doing
murphy the bionic dog is a reminder that
3d printers are already saving lives
today
the surgery went really really well
within a week he was back to his normal
self he has a 3d printed skull it
protects his brain like it's supposed to
and it's absolutely incredible things
that we didn't even know were possible
have now become possible so 3d printing
really is unlimited it's really just
limited by the imagination